[Music]
everyone this is Steve watch out from
Collider and I'm at the collider studio
at the Kia Telluride supper suite at
Sundance with filmmakers behind happy
happy joy joy first let me start by
saying congratulations on the
documentary thank you very much
get it what is it like for you guys
being here in Park City I mean this has
to be pretty crazy yeah it's an amazing
experience I mean this is our first
feature first featured doc first time at
Sundance so it's been a little
overwhelming but it's everybody it's
best so everybody's been so incredibly
kind and supportive so it's really been
a great experience I know that most
people who are fans of Ren and Stimpy
they know happy happy joy joy
but let's since there's a lot of people
watching that might not be familiar talk
a little bit about the doc and what it's
about sure so the doc is about Ren &
Stimpy which was this revolutionary
cartoon that premiered on Nickelodeon
but what makes it so extraordinary is
not only the artwork and the voice I
mean it's just from a craft and artistic
point of view it's it's really a work of
art but also it's incredibly subversive
and this happened this aired long before
Adult Swim so if you look at beavis and
butt-head and South Park and anything on
Adult Swim it really had its genesis to
Ren and Stimpy where one boy one of the
things that people might not realize
though he's and by the way I learned I I
know a lot about Ren & Stimpy but I
learned a lot actually watching your
documentary that I had no idea about how
much did you guys like that this must
have been a really big learning
experience - absolutely it was a huge
learning experience um so I had never
seen an episode until we started this
documentary and he had seen maybe one in
college
probably half drunk so it was it was it
was a week yeah it was a completely
eye-opening experience what we started
to watch episodes to see what we were
getting into it's so interesting because
for me Ren and Stimpy is still like it's
right in simpie
and it's amazing to me that nobody had
thought to do a documentary on what the
happened until where did this idea like
germinate from yes so a friend of mine
who's in the documentary named Todd
white he was friends with John Kay the
creator of Ren and Stimpy
so I was shooting short docs at the time
just you know little things here and
there and he said um you need to do a
doc on this guy because I know him and I
can get you to interview with him and
he's a crazy dude and he did this crazy
show so I was like alright we'll set it
up you know and it took a couple of
years to get that to happen but then Ron
the timing worked out that run was
looking to do something sort of creative
and he said do you have any ideas dude
let's do a doc so I said well all I got
is is Ren & Stimpy thing like I don't
know much about it but if you want to
try to do that we can do that he's like
alright so we just went to our computers
and about an hour later you know we did
some research in that hour later we're
like dude we got a we got to do this cuz
nobody there was a couple little YouTube
things that fans had done but there was
no definitive when you when you realized
we want to do a ran in Stimpy doc at
what moment are you starting to freak
out that maybe because once an idea gets
put in the universe it feels like other
people pick up on that idea so were you
all of a sudden like wait a minute like
you know what I mean like that urgency
yeah absolutely especially because you
know 90s nostalgia is big right now
excuse me and and so inevitably like you
said that once once the idea is out
there in the ether many other people
seem to pick it up it was just like the
25th anniversary of the show so there
was a sense of urgency and you know
being our first film I think the naivete
played into it because we actually shot
for about six months before we
approached Nickelodeon to get the rights
which is a really really bad idea it's a
terrible idea it's awful but to their
credit they said look as long as you
don't disparage the network and we are
you know we will license the material we
don't want final cut but we do want to
see you know what you end up with and I
don't know if you know this but we
actually had to complete versions of the
film the first version was without John
Kay and it was a celebration of the of
the
the series of Ren & Stimpy and it was
done it was a year and a half in the
making it was through post and then four
days later the news broke about John K
in the me2 moment and we freaked out
we're like we now have a film that's
toxic who's gonna watch a celebration
when you know these accusations have
been made against the creator so we
spent a couple weeks got our bearings
and then now created the film that you
see here did you had you interviewed
John I think you had interviewed John
prior to the oh no no so he yeah he
refused even with the introduction from
Todd white the artist that kemo spoke of
John refused to be interviewed I mean we
were after him for a year and a half it
wasn't until the accusations broke and
BuzzFeed and elsewhere that he decided
and reached out to us through an
intermediary and said okay maybe maybe
I'll sit down with you guys and it still
took another six months before he
actually got him on camera because I was
gonna say I was I watched the doc
without knowing exactly where it was all
gonna go and when I saw John on screen
I'm like oh wow they really got him yeah
like yeah it was a long process to get
it looks easy but it took a like I don't
think it was easy no I was gonna say we
spend a lot of time with him to get him
to sit down to get comfortable with us
we did a lot of UFC fight nights at his
house we did a lot of dinners a lot of
lunches just to get him to trust us you
know and and tell him what we really
wanted to to do with the stock so if I'm
not mistaken you did some IndieGoGo
financing for this did you try to do
financing like on its own or did you
immediately realize we let's just do
IndieGoGo well that's a good question
we started with IndieGoGo and then we
had like I said that first version of
the film and then when we realized we
had to do a completely new film I sold
my house and got rid of my car and here
we are Wow yeah
oh so you you did everything you're not
supposed to do on this correct
all in all yeah well first of all I'm
pretty confident that it's is it for
sale it is so submarines handling the
sales rights and I know they're talking
to some folks but I was gonna say I'm
pretty confident you're gonna sell this
movie in fact I'm willing to wager you
know my you know what I mean I put money
on the line that you guys are selling
we really need to get run a car mostly
because there's so much interest in Ren
& Stimpy absolutely and you guys made a
really compelling doc that's thank you
really what you know what I mean yeah
like if the talk was [ __ ] you'd be in
trouble yeah you know you guys did it
thank you very much so talk a little bit
about how much did you have a lot of
stuff that ended up being on the cutting
room floor in terms of because I would
imagine you shot a lot of material yeah
we did like 53 interviews and there's
just so much I mean we wanted to do a
cut that was three and a half hours long
you know but you just can't do that and
there's so much amazing material we have
but you just you just have no choice you
have to move forward and if it's not
advancing the story you just you got to
leave it where it is but we will have
DVD extras and a lot of that stuff will
be on there so there's a lot of stories
being told a lot of crazy stuff that
happened at spunk o where they made Ren
Stimpy stuff that we couldn't just put
in because we had to sort of narrow our
focus that I mean the doc is already an
hour and 40 minutes so but yeah for DVD
extras it's gonna be yeah you're talking
to that many talented artists you can
imagine so many of them are great
storytellers you're just transfixed and
the first cut we did just as our own
director's cut it was two and a half
hours long and we're like oh this is too
long I am interested because so many of
those people are so talented I would
imagine that they I would imagine
there's some great as you said great
stories I'm just wondering like how much
like I can imagine how much stuff but 80
hours of footage is what we cut down
exactly so I want to ask having done the
question I got from Dave who did the
review having done in-depth interviews
with John his crew and Robin Byrne how
do you personally see the legacy of Ren
& Stimpy that's a really complicated
question and something that we
definitely wanted to leave open for the
audience cuz here's here's the tricky
part and and it we're seeing this across
entertainment as these allegations and
truths come out about various creators
having done really terrible things is
that millions of people have been
affected by the art and and we
interviewed other fans that are in the
documentary that would tell these
incredibly compelling stories about you
know the last time I saw my mom smile
was when we were watching
Ren and Stimpy together before she died
a cancer so to get somebody like that to
just completely scrap and stop watching
Ren and Stimpy it's probably not gonna
happen you know on the other side of
that equation you have people like Robin
Bird and and and others not Robin was an
extreme case for sure but others at work
with John and suffered abuse that had
these you know have these incredibly
compelling stories and and you can't
help but feel for them it's like how do
you balance that and and that's not
necessarily a question that we wanted to
answer and it was really important for
us in this documentary to present the
facts and not give an opinion because we
feel these days like every outlet gives
you an opinion you're either a CNN
person or a fox person and and we've
kind of felt it leads to a little bit of
an intellectual laziness so we wanted to
present the case from a neutral
viewpoint and then have people make
their own decisions yeah yeah you know
and and also addressing the separating
the art from the artist you know that
was a big thing for us as some people
can do it so people can't and that's
their choice you know so that's just
something that we have to leave for
people too that you know you can't I
mean if you grew up watching this show
for years and using all these memories
just to you know like Ron was saying
just to be able to just oh I can't stand
that show anymore you know I I don't
know if it's the same thing with Michael
Jackson so much out there and time is
another issue you know after time starts
to pass unfortunately it just gets
people like yeah you know they forget
about things sure you know what
obviously you two learned a lot about
Ren & Stimpy while making this what do
you think like what are some of the
things that really really surprised you
in terms of you know stuff that you
learned about the making of the show or
behind the scenes you know it was it was
done during a time when digital was just
coming so everything was hand done I
mean if you think of animation or
filmmaking in general it's 24 frames a
second right and then however many
seconds and minutes and hours so they
had a hand draw 24 frames a second and
you just look at this
still frames which you'll see a lot of
the original artwork in the film and and
and just the amount of emotion and that
that is has communicated through a
simple line drawing is just
extraordinary yeah I completely agree
just the amount of work that it took to
get the show off the ground and and a
lot of the artists that like Chris Rock
Rd those guys would go off and then
create music for the show after doing
you know 16 hours in an animation studio
they go into a music studio and then
write happy happy joy joy or write songs
uh just the passion that these guys had
um the drive to do that where most
people like okay I'm going to go home
and crack a beer these guys were like no
you know they just had so much care for
what they were doing so that to me just
blew me away I was like wow I couldn't
believe how much not only work and they
just they were just so committed you
know it was just yeah I wonder
especially after watching the doc like
obviously John let's just say went a
little insane and I wonder if they had
nowadays they do less episodes you know
like certain series but you you have to
wonder do you think if Nickelodeon had
come back to them after that huge
success and said we just need like six
more do you think John like after
talking to people would have still gone
as crazy as he did or do you think that
it was just the success and the pressure
no matter what it was gonna be would
just do him in you know I think the show
would have just kept getting bigger and
bigger I mean it's definitely there was
a lot of great episodes after John left
but the show really kind of tapered off
in terms of popularity and you know as
many people told us that this very well
could have gone on for years like The
Simpsons and how John would have reacted
it's really hard to say I mean you know
it he's a perfectionist that yeah and
he's a gnarly perfectionist so that guy
will not accept anything subpar right
you know so it is it's a tough tough
prediction on that ya know and if
somebody said you know it probably would
have been better as specials like you
said like six episodes a year as opposed
to trying to force him to deliver twenty
or however many ultimately it's
interesting because I think that listen
I give him a lot of credit
for putting together such an all-star
team of animators all the people that
worked on it and you know his
inventiveness of doing created by
storyboard by giving the proper credit
to people you know he literally changed
everything in terms of that came after
that's that's right I mean you didn't
see that created by credit you didn't
see cartoons as an art or medium four
years I mean it was back in the bob
clampett warner brothers forties era but
further that you know what 40 years 50
years you didn't see that
and then as he broke down that barrier
you're starting to see you know them
South parks and the Mike judges for
beavis and butt-head etc I have to ask
of course you when did you finish we
finished
well we finished cutting but what three
months ago or so and then finished
fairly quickly after that but in terms
of shooting we were done shooting about
a year ago I would say I mean when was
the last time you worked on the movie so
like three months ago yeah yeah that's
it that's about it so after you took up
like a few days and you know have you
even started thinking about what's our
next dock or is it we were thinking
about that like a year ago you know at
this point we have to keep it private
because it's it's more celebrity based
with people that are two people in
particular they're very well-known that
have these extraordinary stories above
and beyond what their public images so
we don't want to quite give that away
yet but don't blame you I would say
though it will probably be a lot easier
for you to now that you have this talk
under your belt so you can be like well
check this out yeah yeah it's like you
know you know what I mean yeah
absolutely I mean it was really
difficult to get those initial
interviews because we had never done a
doc before and it was like calling
people up and saying I know you went
through this horrendous professional
divorce but will you tell a stranger
about it on camera
yeah and just in general learning the
process of documentary filmmaking you
know we've learned so much just what to
do what not to do you know that kind of
thing so just having that is already a
huge leg up on that note I'm just gonna
say congrats on the documentary thank
you thank you so much for coming in
thank you and I hope it sells tomorrow
thank you very much such a pleasure